good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
a new primary care practice has come to
our communities rescue and they're all
about
senior focused care here's how
good to see you again we're telling our
viewers about partners in primary care
introduce them
well partners in primary care is a
senior focused
primary care practice that just came
into las vegas
and we've opened up clinics here six new
clinics so far what is senior focused
care exactly
people over 65 are in a different phase
of their lives and they have different
needs
and we have a model that's been designed
to help patients
from a behavioral point of view
physically socially emotionally
and what we've done with that it's about
giving you more
time and really truly being your partner
in primary care
so it's more time more space more
respect that you deserve so the whole
team can address
the patient's concerns it starts with an
entire care team actually
we have doctors nurses behavioral health
specialists and a clinical pharmacist
all here that are specially trained in
the needs of seniors
and in that we can provide every single
little need that they have and address
future concerns
and we also have offices that are
dedicated to seniors
we have convenient parking you can park
right up in front
we have spaces that and rooms that
accommodate wheelchairs
walkers and we also have an activity
center with live activities
virtual programming so there's really a
lot going on here and we want to keep
seniors moving
engaged physically and mentally happy
and healthy
are you guys actually taking new
patients oh yes we are
um even during this difficult covered
time we are
taking measures to make sure we keep our
patients safe
and we also are giving patients the
option to do telemedicine
visits so it could be telehealth we can
meet a virtually on computer
on the phone or various ways perfect
and of course it's time for flu shots do
you guys recommend people come in and do
that with you guys
oh absolutely you know these days now
flu shot
isn't just prevention for you getting
the flu it's very important to protect
your family
and everybody else around you it's
actually an act of love
when you're taking care of yourself by
giving yourself a flu shot
you're helping everybody else in the
community at large
and also at this time while it won't
protect you against
covid it will protect you against the
flu
and if you wind up getting the flu you
might have an increased risk
of getting coveted so we are
recommending everybody
please get your flu vaccines now and you
can call today to become a patient here
we can
get your flu vaccine here
for more information call partners in
primary care at 702-623-3774